dream come true to be a video game
character you know you didn't want to be
a new doesn't want to be a video game
character there's not a lot of people
that made the cook you know it only
select you people made the call i'm
honored that they chose me so it's a
dream come true
I didn't want to come in here in satsang
flying spinning stuff because I knew
that the journalists had to try it
themselves and so we just traveled some
basic stuff some stuff to give them an
understanding of different areas that
the fight could possibly take place some
other to show different variations of
the fight some standard moves and
overhand right cuz I'm leg kicks um and
then we showed a single leg takedown
then we show to move against the fence
because defense is a big part of the
contest techniques restless in addition
to use against the fish I know it's
great for anywhere else i zoom in and
then we showed some transition from the
on the ground as well it falls in you
were triangle here have a look at it the
game is phenomenal that the movements
are accurately the detail in my faces is
a crazy it's a bit weird looking at the
to be honest book it's a phenomenal game
and ass and I think I think what this
game will do for a lot of people here in
Ireland and what I think what the very
first one done was educate people on the
different areas of the game because that
actually playing in our anonymous today
they become more educated and they
understand it a bit Muslim and actually
watch the events or participated in it
the game has actually taught them
something so it works out perfectly one
hundred percent just in that game I was
playing I knocked out the econo champion
jose aldo with a front hook kick that's
as realistic as it gets
hey
you